وضعت في قاعدة عسكرية سعودية
بقايا صاروخ باليستي أطلق
من اليمن بعض شظايا الصاروخ
مثل هذه يقول السعوديون الصغيرون
إنها مبعثرة عبر الصحراء من
حيث أسقط نظامهم الصاروخي المضاد للصواريخ الباليستية
هذا أثناء تحليقه
نحو  سي إن إن العاصمة هي أول
طاقم إخباري يتم عرض هذا الصاروخ الحوثي
الذي تم إسقاطه الشهر الماضي على بعد حوالي 15 ميلاً
من الرياض ، وهذا دليل على أن المسؤولين
هنا يقولون إن إيران تدعم المتمردين اليمنيين
الذين يزدادون الهجمات التي
تستهدف
المدنيين
السعوديين.  جانب من الصاروخ الذي
أقنع السعوديين بأن هذه
صناعة إيرانية ، يقولون إن عليهم إجراء
المزيد من الاختبارات على هذا
التحليل العلمي للمعادن التي يتعين عليهم إلقاء نظرة
على المتفجرات وإلقاء نظرة على
لوحات الدوائر الإلكترونية هنا وكذلك
فحص رقم الأسلاك  على
سبيل المثال ، حيث تم جعل الرقائق الموجودة على
لوحة الدائرة مصدر قلقهم الفوري على
الرغم من أن صاروخًا يضرب
سكان العاصمة أكثر  هناك سبعة
ملايين ونصف المليون شخص من الحوثيين يجب أن
يعرفهم حتى مع العمل العدائي هناك
ضوء أحمر ما هو الخط الأحمر يمكننا أن نشير
إلى الخط الأحمر ولكن إذا كانت نقطتنا الحيوية
أو شعبنا قد
تأثروا بسبب الباليستية
الصاروخ المقدس لديه هناك
ليفترض أنه سيكون مؤلمًا للغاية ،
فهو ليس التصعيد الأخير الوحيد
الذي يقلق السعوديين هذا الشهر
يقول المسؤولون السعوديون إنهم أوقفوا
هجومًا حوثيًا بمساعدة إيرانية على
ناقلة نفط في البحر الأحمر.
قد تأتي الهجمات ، لكن كل من
هجمات الشحن والصواريخ تشير إلى
انتشار مفرط خطير محتمل للحرب الأهلية اليمنية ،
ويقول السعوديون إنهم يعتقدون أن
هذا الصاروخ الضخم قد تم تهريبه إلى
اليمن في أجزاء منفصلة ، والدليل
الذي يقولون أنه في اللحام هنا
أنواع مختلفة من اللحام المغطاة
بدرجات مختلفة من الطلاء ، آخرها
تم إطلاقه واعتراضه قبل 30 دقيقة
أو قبل ساعة واحدة الآن وصلنا
إلى 88 دولة في المملكة العربية
السعودية  تلقت 80
صاروخًا باليستيًا من صاحب القلنسوة في
الأشهر القليلة الماضية ، فقد ارتفعت وتيرة الهجمات الصاروخية
مع إطلاق المزيد من الصواريخ على
المدن الكبرى.